the journalist appeared briefly in a
Moscow Courthouse
and afterwards was briefly seen being
taken away in a car to be held elsewhere
in custody
they held a quick trial I don't know it
took three maybe 15 minutes
a spokesperson for the Russian foreign
Ministry admitted gershkovich had a
press visa and official accreditation
but claimed he was arrested for what she
described as a different kind of
activity than journalism his employer
says the Wall Street Journal vehemently
denies the allegations from the FSB and
seeks the immediate release of our
trusted and dedicated reporter we stand
in solidarity with Evan and his family
affluent Russian speaker the 31 year old
has been reporting from the region for
more than six years
the reaction from the White House was
angry
this Espionage charges are ridiculous
the targeting of American citizens by
Russian government is unacceptable
we condemn the Detention of Mr gerskovic
in the strongest in the strongest terms
we also condemn the Russian government's
continued targeting and repression of
journalists
the U.S state department has been in
close contact with the detained
journalist's employer
first the U.S embassy in Moscow has
requested official notification of the
arrest and Russia is required to provide
that under our bilateral Consular
convention second whenever U.S citizens
are arrested abroad we pursue Consular
access as soon as possible however due
to Russia's administrative procedures
and security requirements it will likely
be several days before that happens
the ongoing Russian military campaign in
Ukraine has brought relations with the
US to its lowest point in decades dating
back to the height of the Cold War which
was the last time Russia arrested a U.S
journalist on the charge of spying
Vincent Monahan Al Jazeera